this morning cache in the age of covert
19 the pandemic appears to be
accelerating the rise of digital
currency here in the u.s. mobile
payments have spiked dramatically since
the outbreak in the UK the BBC reports
ATM withdrawals are down 60% China's
central bank has reportedly been
disinfecting banknotes while many
businesses around the world are asking
customers not to use cash at all it's
all making some wonder if the digital
dollar is the new king of currency brook
silva-braga follow the money at the
Green Market in New York's Union Square
the shewolf bakery has a request please
pay with card or phone your actively
asking people not to use cash we're not
demanding it but we're asking it you
know shopper Becky Shepherd doesn't need
to be asked twice germs all over but
money is very filthy before paying
employees with the cash they get the
mountain sweet Berry Farm says they now
cook it so there's a steaming tray with
holes and we put the lay the money out
and steam it boom
clean money interesting does that make
you feel more safe yes yes any step that
we can to make us feel a little safer
and to make everybody else feel a little
safer we're gonna do it's worth noting
there haven't been any documented cases
of corona virus spread through cash it
survives much better on plastic like a
credit card or credit card reader and
yes the biggest danger at checkout is
probably in the air the droplets
carrying the virus are believed to most
often spread but fear may be driving new
spending habits anyway in the first
quarter of the year MasterCard reported
a 40% jump in the use of contactless
payment options that's when you wave a
card or phone pastor reader without even
touching it peter reuter gear covers
digital payments for The Wall Street
Journal what are my contactless payment
options the big one is with your phone
so that is your credit card it's just
your credit card stored on your phone
and what these payment methods have
lacked for a long time is just a reason
that it's
you need to use them and your credit
card but if I say what if now it's just
safer because you don't have to touch a
screen you can just type your phone
I think that'll convince more people
there's another big factor driving the
shift in transactions so much of what we
used to do in person has had to move
online looks like I'm online and all the
platforms for years
Katy Ferrara traveled the world and
opened her guitar case
now she stream shows from her living
room in LA
[Music]
in an hour she can make $200 and how do
people pay you
PayPal in venmo are actually sister
companies that both let users send money
with a few taps on a phone or computer
and they're both run by CEO Dan Schulman
are there ways that people are using
your service that are new that or maybe
even surprising we've seen is
acceleration of some trends that we're
always happening in the background but
now are dramatically accelerating one of
them is a blurring of the line between
ecommerce and traditional retail like
paying by scanning a curbside QR code
and avoiding a register altogether
you're already seeing retailers we're
getting ready to open who are
reimagining the way that they do the
checkout experience in fact some of them
are gonna have just checkout lanes for
cash only and so think about it as sort
of EZ Pass and cash only tolls on
highways you're gonna see a separation
of checkout but if cash gets harder to
use what happens to the 20 million
Americans living in households without a
bank account an earlier push to go
cashless spurred a backlash and laws
requiring businesses to take it
the first was passed in Philadelphia by
City Councilman William Greenlee who we
profiled last fall telling people who do
not have the ability to have credit that
you can't buy a basic product is not
treating people fairly but with digital
transactions here to stay
senator sherrod Brown is legislating in
the other direction
the Ohio Democrat is proposing to give
every American a debit card linked to a
free bank account you'd sign up at a
local bank branch work even the post
office we call it a Fed account it would
be administered through the Federal
Reserve the Federal Reserve has the
technology to do this if for whatever
reason legislation or legislation like
this can't
asked do you think the private sector
steps in and kind of solves this problem
I think there's some things the private
sector doesn't do I mean the banks don't
really seem interested in low-income
people because they can't make a lot of
money off them so that's why we want to
allow our post offices and our community
banks working with the Federal Reserve
to give people that option we'd back in
the farmers market we noticed many
shoppers we're still using cash
you know we saw right when the
coronavirus happened big withdrawals
from ATMs and banks and there's
something about cash that people just
don't want to entirely give up even in
the age of Karuna cash isn't quite ready
to give up its crown a lot of the older
people who say we take cash or venmo
they'll say what's venmo and my answer
is something you don't have CBS this
morning Saturday brook silva-braga New
York that's pretty good something you
you don't have but I mean Dana there are
there are a lot of people who still like
to deal with cash although that debit
card idea you if everyone has one then
your cashless but you can still use it
yeah I mean the idea obviously is to
make sure that everybody has that access
and it is interesting I'm a venmo or an
Apple pay person but I found myself also
going to get cash because I still have
in the back of my mind what happens if
we can't access something digitally
electronically that kind of thing we
will see as we go ahead